We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p.
Here's an interesting question, uh, which
relates to a lot of different things we talk
about on the show.
Take a listen.
Hi, my name is James Offering Security Ohio.
Do a great job.
Thank you for everything you do.
You are very articulate.
You formed your sister's physicists really
well.
Thank you.
Why?
You know you're quick on your feet, so to
STI and that's a skill that I'm just really
struggling yet.
I'm wondering if that's a skill that you've
always had since you were a little kid or
if it's somebody you really had to develop
on.
I would like to be more our articulate when
I speak on my feet like you do in sound vaguely
more intelligent.
I just want, did you have any advice or if
you've also had any struggles in the past
that you've had to work for a mentor or if
it's just something that came natural to you.
That's all.
Thank you again.
Thanks for being here.
Bye.
Here's the thing.
Thinking on your feet and being articulate.
Anthony Fantano actually has a really good
video about this on one of his channels, about
how to be articulate.
There's two parts to it.
There is subject matter knowledge which does
matter.
Okay.
And beyond that it's just social comfort and
uh, comfort, uh, in situations where one needs
to think on their feet.
And I have no, uh, question whatsoever why
I developed the comfort and it's the jobs
I held from the time that I was young.
When I was 14, I started working at a laser
tag place.
I actually got a work permit from the school
superintendent who said, David's doing okay
enough in school that I am going to allow
him to have a job instead of having to wait
until he's 16.
And I worked at a laser tag place and I was
the person who had to deal with angry parents
because their kids equipment, their laser
tag gun wasn't working and handle payments
and all of this stuff.
At age 14, I had to be able to think on my
feet and deal with parents and kids and people
of all ages in college, kids coming in, uh,
drunk to play, laser tag and whatever else.
I then worked at circuit city as a salesperson,
the now defunct electronics retail chain.
And I was constantly dealing with angry people
because their TV's not working right or the
laptop's not working right or trying to sell
extended service plans to people and having
to in the moment sort of gauge what sort of
sales technique would best work.
Uh, it was just that and that is how, uh,
I, it's just a matter of practice and developing
confidence and social comfort, sort of the
opposite of like a social anxiety, um, is
what, what I think most, uh, most helps there.
And also having some subject matter knowledge.
I think that there is no, I mean, listen,
maybe there were, there were PR I recently
read, catch me if you can by Frank Aben Yala
or ebony.
I, I'm not sure how he pronounces his last
name.
Uh, he may have been a skilled enough con
man.
We're in a complete void of subject matter
knowledge.
He could appear to be knowledgeable about
something.
Um, for most people I think you actually need
to have the subject matter knowledge and the
area in which you are trying to be a are articulate
and we've got a great bonus show for you today.
A college board is dropping it's adversity
score for students after major backlash.
We will talk about Kentucky Fried Chicken
or I guess now it just called KFC trying plant
based chicken nuggets and wings in the United
States.
And we will also talk about Youtube CEO saying
that it is more important than ever to let
people upload whatever they want to upload
to youtube.
That's interesting.
And there is a double meaning there that I
am going to talk about on today's bonus, Joe,
become a member,
join pacman.com or a patron at patrion.com/david
Pakman show to get instant access to today's
bonus show.
I'll speak to you down the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.